my dad's actually
super critical your dad is critical of
you yeah he is he is he he played like
he's he's in marketing like nobody in my
family's in the industry and um he
played like the back end of a donkey in
like the nativity play when he was five
years old and he thinks that he's daniel
day-lewis
and so when i go home he asks for like
the grey scripts and he makes me reenact
scenes with him where he's like mcdreamy
and he makes like a living room an
operating theater and then he tells me
stuff like i didn't really believe that
smile you just gave oh my god sweet
morty he's very hardcore does he
criticize other things in your life is
it just your acting has he ever
criticized other work you've done um
well i i did the struggling waitressing
thing
um you know trying to act and uh he came
in and i waited on him once and he
complained to my manager that my service
what for real seriously that my service
was slow i was like and i was like dad
like isn't it that we share dna isn't
there like some sort of loyalty here and
he was like darling but you know it was
be honest it was slow
your father comes into a restaurant
where you're a waitress and then
complains about me about you that's just
that shouldn't happen no no no no no
something's wrong with you
something's really how long did you have
to waitress for
oh man i
a good handful of years and i was i'm
not gonna lie i wasn't the best
but um and i didn't really like it but
there was one particular
seriously painful shift i will always
remember
and um i had audition of this amazing
indie movie this one week and i had done
a chemistry reader between me and
another girl and what's a chemistry
chemistry chemistry readers where you
basically get into a room with a with
the lead actor and you pray that you
have chemistry and they decide and you
have to like it's awkward you have to
like make out with them and you know
just be in love and clearly we had no
chemistry because he picked the other
girl and the movie went on to do like
absolutely amazing and she was in like
vanity fair but anyway so i didn't get
it i was so disappointed i was so upset
and i was waitressing that next week and
i came outside to my section
and
i realized that the director the guy who
like said that i he had no chemistry
with me and the girl that got my role
was sat on my table
and i had to wait on them
while they
talked about like what they were going
to do in each scene and i was like hot
wings
i was like does anyone need i'm sorry i
don't mean to anyone needed some level
of
yeah
crappy sports bar so i was like covered
in ranch i wasn't even like looking cute
i was like covered in ranch dressing why
were you covered in ranch dressing by
the way i've been to sports
yes i've been there and they don't let
me put ranch dressing all over the girls
well i was and we had like embarrassing
names for stuff so i was like nachos
mama's nachos i mean it was like just so
humiliating right and the guy is there
who made up a week ago and was like no i
don't think so yeah and he's like i'll
take another coke
oh my god what a jerk yeah
well we're not like that we're guys you
can trust yeah yeah yeah
we're good guys yeah
we'll do anything you see the back of
your shirt yeah look at that you don't
have any ranch dressing back here